how's your night going nick what
that was so bad how's your night going
that's almost as bad as my pickup line
welcome everyone to the group chat this
is round one the speed round i
am third wheel come along fellas there
we are henrik
alex zachary hello hello what i'm
looking for in one of these guys
is a good balance maybe 50 50
attractiveness both on the outside
and the inside that'd be great a little
sparkle nerdiness too that'd be swell
i'm so nervous
question what's your ideal first date in
three emojis
i'm so curious this is intense i'm kind
of feeling bad for them
to be honest if i were in their shoes my
goodness
oh barry has a little a game emoji
figure a robot and a disco dancer that's
adorable heino
has music tacos and a castle that's dope
henrik sunsets
flowers and stars that's so sweet
mascara racing
let's choose out and i don't like sushi
avalon make your first elimination
oh my mother freaking gosh i feel really
bad
zachary you gotta go
we'll miss you man we'll hit you up here
yeah hey let's chill sometime dog
i don't even know what diamond thumbs up
and disco dancer what
and like you were the last one to
respond have some urgency dear zachary
here is the camera of the exit
just so as you eliminate them you can
see yeah who you eliminated
oh my goodness oh
oh he was actually really cute well dang
this is a game of wit what's the biggest
dating deal breaker for you
somebody always on their phone during
the day that's a very easy response
lack of sense of humor talking and not
listening dang it i have to make the
answer this is hard
this is so hard um alex i love your
punctuation but
darling that was a boring answer even
though it's true
i feel so bad oh my gosh did i make the
wrong decision
oh shucks mommy oh
i'm kind of regretting that one he was
very very attractive
next question what's your latest
favorite tv show
black mirror i saw an episode of that
it's kind of disturbing makes me wonder
about his sanity the office
cole darling i love you i'm nicolas co
con
no that's a cool name though the
stranger thing sounds so basic
[Applause]
oh oh poor thing you couldn't even look
at the camera i feel terrible but you
know it's the survival of the fittest
next step send a picture of the shirt
you're wearing make sure it's cute henry
nice nice necklace i'm getting a little
extra detail reginald
fashionable oh cole huh cole's wearing a
flamingo button up
ooh brandon you look sexy baby what the
heck
that's that's a oh sorry i didn't mean
to objectify you
cole you gotta go flamingos scammer
cool you are so funny i wish i could
have kept you
and then there were three
what's your best feature leo energy
my sense of humor hey okay i'm always
asked
how's the weather up there i'd say my
height i love
their answers oh my gosh oh no no
oh yay bear is the one who said the
height i'm
very short i'm borderline 5-2 that's not
gonna fly
i don't want to fly so let's go with
nacho
oh i'm sorry barry now there's two
welcome to round two private mode but
first a little mood setter
oh boy
[Music]
you can decide who you want to talk to
first i choose brendan
no no no i choose her what are you
looking for in a partner in one sentence
oh dang it he has a good he's good at
this there's not really an answer
i just like what he said kind soul
creative spirit and a genuine connection
to their interests passions that's
exactly what i think see henrik is very
very funny and he's very clever
he's very goofy i'm getting a mental
image
of what i think he could potentially
look like i wish i could read minds i'm
a philosophy major that probably gives
me
some mind inside oh my freaking gosh a
philosophy major
oh wow he's quick really i would have to
pick teleportation there are so many
brilliant places to visit
yeah but if you could read minds
then you can like read someone's mind
who is capable of transporting you to
places
and figure out how to communicate with
them so that they can transport you to
those places so that like the
possibilities are endless
now how to get that into text so i get
to choose whether i want to hear a voice
memo of him telling me about his perfect
date or get a picture of his facial
features
one of the most attractive things for me
is somebody's voice
it's always been weird but like that's a
big deal voice memo please
oh he wants a voice memo too oh i think
my perfect date
would either be something that's super
duper early in the morning like going to
a diner
when it's like nobody's there yet or
really late at night
and walking around again where nobody
else is there that would be my perfect
day i'm not one
who enjoys like plans and things like
that and even just great times hanging
out with my friends
have just involved scheduling to go to
places and then deciding instead to just
wander around downtown and watch the
sunset
i'm not really one to care much for what
we're doing just spending quality time
together you know oh that's cute we have
the same length of voice memo
a woman of extremes yes henrik yes
i'm pretty big on sleep so i would
probably be on the later end of that
metric
oh that sucks that's like what i really
hope to find in a partner somebody who'd
be willing to wake up really early
just like hey wake up meet me here i
know it's 2 am but let's go
i want pancakes what's something that
few people know about you
good question i'd say that i'm super
sedated and chill i think i come off as
really like
energetic but most of the time i'm very
i'm very quiet i just like sitting and
reading and doing nothing
monkeys i love monkeys i
want a finger monkey i feel great
yeah i really like him he's funny the
morning thing is definitely an issue
though i mean i could get over it but
that's disappointing evelyn and brendan
welcome to round two
what's been the hardest part about
dating i don't really like anybody
i'd say finding someone with the same
level of commitment also it's too app
heavy
agreed you don't like anyone
nah avalon you may ask brendan to send
you his
favorite instagram he's taken or a voice
memo and where he sees himself in 10
years
lego voiso oh yes for the voice memo as
well
in 10 years i see myself fully satisfied
with life
a blossoming business a happy
personal life good gracious why is this
so freaking hard
i promise i'm motivated and driven i
swear brendan don't you worry
just give me more time to think which we
don't have
no it's so bad i have two ideal options
either
being a professor at a university or
working in production making films i'd
be more so
passionate working in the film industry
what would you do if you won the lottery
i would invest my money
into my friends companies to make more
money
money for everybody travel for a year
then get to work on long-term goals
where would you travel to dear brendan
australia new zealand i need to go there
heck yeah
i wanna go to iceland if you could
change one thing about yourself what
would it be
one thing take away any negative
thoughts i like his answer i changed my
ability to handle strict
stressful situations you said you
sounded pretty defeat
see there it is again the misconception
i feel pretty confident in myself and
who i am as a person so
like and i think i did a good job of
communicating the things that i'm
interested in
i'm pretty stoked to meet avalon
hopefully and to go forward with this
i think if we were to go on a real date
we'd be able to
elaborate a little bit more like bounce
back and forth if she were to ask i'd
definitely say yes so this was very
frustrating and i'm all about
quick witted humor quick weighted
comments like this is making you think
you're not really getting the whole of
them you're getting
parts of them after much thought i'm
really nervous
hi there hi brendan nice to meet you
as well pleasure to meet you both this
is absolutely
hard and i'm so sorry who will not be
moving forward and who will be going
home if that's where you're going
is um brendan
ah henrik's great you're great so it was
it was great
no problem
you need me
oh he says hi
you're a fantastic person we have
similar interests in a lot of ways and
i'm stoked to get to know you better
honestly i didn't really expect to make
to the final two so there's some pride
to be found in that can i actually get
your number
yeah i mean we've been texting so much
anyways i know
avalon you've been emailed an arc-like
gift card to use as you please
maybe go to a movie do i absolutely
[Music]
you